[Music]
okay
so this is my spoiler-free review
of the haunting of bly manor let me just
say the haunting of hill house
was my favorite horror show ever made
and it was a bright spot for that year
on netflix
i think season one is an absolute
masterpiece and was a game changer so
having said that
i had huge expectations for its
follow-up in the haunting blind manner
knowing this is now an anthology series
going under the haunting so it was
exciting to see mike flanagan still the
showrunner
helming this thing but you have to
understand this always happens with
season two that
in season one he directed and wrote
every single episode
here he wrote and directed only the
premiere
that had me worried however the good
news is i
still really enjoy this show
there's a couple things though you have
to understand one i can't say much
because they have some really strict
things we cannot talk about
in our spoiler free reviews so i'm gonna
just gloss over
and generalize some stuff for you
there's gonna be a lot of surprise
actors in this surprise how they fit
into all
of it and you have to watch this twice i
watched this straight through
the whole season and was incredibly
disappointed and i really
actually didn't like it and then i
watched it again and it was a completely
different show because once you know
what's going on
it like blows you away how well thought
out it was all the themes make sense
and it it really is like vital and if
you don't like that you have to watch
something twice and it's that layered
then don't watch the show you're not
gonna like it but you probably didn't
like hill house then either
so if it's something that you like that
makes you think and makes you
have re-watch value it's this but you
have to understand when you watch it
you're gonna feel feelings of emptiness
disappointment
you're gonna expect haunting of hill
house in a sense it's
different in many ways because it's not
every episode
centered on one character let's say it's
a little
different of a ball game and the way
they pace it's different and a lot of
things are gonna take you by surprise
certain decisions they make
but it's not gonna feel satisfying at
first watch i
guarantee it but if you watch it a
second time you're gonna be
really really impressed now what i will
say
is in this whole series now of the
haunting
the haunting blind manor does have the
first clunker of an episode to me an
actually bad episode of television
which will be i'll say it right now
episode 6 of season 2.
i did not like this episode for many
reasons which you'll see in my spoiler
review when that comes out
that was disappointing that there'd be
an episode of low quality to me
however there's not as consistently
amazing episodes like hill house had but
there's two hill house level episodes of
amazing which is gonna be the finale
here
and episode five now why that's
encouraging
is because one of the weaknesses of hill
house a lot people had a complaint was
the back end of the season and
especially the finale it's ironic now
that blind manor would actually
beat hillhouse in is an amazing finale
that to me knocks it out of the park so
that's a huge
positive what's a big disappointment in
blind manor
is it really isn't scary
at all and season one
wasn't too scary but it had its moments
of terror and like
horrifying scarring stuff this doesn't
even really
try too much at that so that's another
warning i have is that if you really
like
haunted fieldhouse for its writing and
for its character writing and
themes you're gonna get that here and
you're gonna appreciate it and
really have good feelings of emotion but
if you're really looking for like
your scary horror show it is not this
and if you thought haunted field house
wasn't scary enough
you're not gonna find that here either
but what you're gonna find again is
great writing
incredible acting all around every actor
is good here you're gonna see new actors
here that weren't in hawaiian fellas
you're like
how do they find these people they're
all so consistently good it uses
a lot of the same music so it keeps a
kind of nice tone
throughout this haunting series now but
it doesn't rely on it as a crutch
it separates itself enough but there's
also some
over familiarity like it being in a
haunted house again i'm not
too crazy about that and it seems a
little too soon for that especially some
of the interior
looks similar to hill house but if you
watch it on its own it's still great on
its own
doesn't rely on hill house and yes there
will be
some hill house easter eggs and some
hill house connections but not over the
top so it's just right on that
department
and it looks beautiful and the makeup
and hair
and production design is incredible
cinematography
is just awesome and it obviously really
stands out in flanigan's episode episode
one the cinematography but he's able to
find
other writers who are able to pull off
writing
really well which is so hard to do and
that's what worried me but
it's satisfying no it is not as good as
haunting a field house
but who thought it would be that's such
a high standard to live up to
but it's a really good second act and
you know what
most shows season two suck and are real
disappointments
i mean just look at westworld i mean
westworld season one to me was a
masterpiece like haunting people season
was a masterpiece
so to have now a masterpiece show have a
really good season two
makes me happy enough where westworld
was like it went from masterpiece to
garbage so having this not be garbage is
great
and it's gonna give this its upside of
this might end up going down as the best
anthology series ever made
and one of the most consistently good
series ever made so
i'm really happy in that so i'm giving
this season
as a whole 9.2 i can't wait for you guys
to see my spoiler review of the whole
season
and i will also have each episode review
cut up for you guys so if you just want
to watch
by episode again i love haunting
fieldhouse i love the haunting as a
series now
i really dug this season just lower your
expectations
a little bit and you must give it a
second watch and understand the first
watch
might feel like a chore and a little
empty but you're going to get such a
reward if you stick for it for a second
watch it's a totally different
experience it's essential
let me know if you're excited for this
well you're expecting any theories you
got going in
i'd love to hear your thoughts i read
every comment and try to respond as many
as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss any of my reviews and again
so you can see right when that
spoiler review comes out in my episode
by episode breakdown i also do celebrity
interviews as well so you don't want to
miss that
and if you like what i do here please if
you can
sign up for my monthly donation of only
two dollars this will let me
be able to do more videos for you guys
in the future and do this full-time and
it would really help
me and i appreciate any support i can
get and please follow me at steve barley
show
on twitter instagram for more of me and
i'll see you next time